[Music]
it all happened pretty fast Justin and
Selena split in March and Justin and
Hailey reignited their romance just
about a month ago a source tells ET
Justin asked Hayley's father the actor
Stephen Baldwin for her hand in marriage
a couple of weeks ago does your dad like
him that's the big question
both my parents liked him a lot Stephen
Baldwin is also a Christian minister
maybe he could forgives me our source
says Justin and Stephens pre-proposal
meeting included talk about
relationships and religion the more the
son the longer the duck baldwin baptized
Spencer Pratt on the reality show I'm a
celebrity get me out of here in 2009
that same year he introduced Justin to
Haley backstage at The Today Show
Haley look like an unimpressed teen at
the time a big difference from the all
in loved-up look in these images Justin
posted yesterday the Biebs is sporting
facial hair in the pics which prompted
one of his friends to tweet grow the
mustache back for the wedding
Haley is definitely not feeling the look
and fired back don't you dare give him
that idea you lunatic
[Applause]
you